Speaker 1: . OK, we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's a very good question, and I'm going
to be honest with you about the answer.
OK, listen to the question, then I'll give
you my answer.
Speaker 5: Hi, David, this is David from Ohio.
I was just wondering if Trump was still president,
would more people be taking the vaccine?
Would everyone be taking the vaccine?
Would we be better off as a country?
I was just wondering your thoughts on that.
Thanks, Alison.
Speaker 1: Yes, it is undeniable that if Donald
Trump were president right now, more Americans
would be vaccinated.
There is no question because the people who
follow science who are vaccinated today would
still be vaccinated if Trump were president.
But there would be millions of Trump ists
who have not gotten the vaccine because it
has been Joe Biden overseeing its rollout
who would have gotten vaccinated if Trump
were president.
Now, the second question is tougher.
Would we be better off as a country?
That's harder to say because Trump was such
an unmitigated, unmitigated disaster.
I think long term, we're better off with Joe
Biden rather than Trump, even though you would
have more.
Trump is vaccinated if Trump were president.
But I fully admit the people that care about
rhetoric rather than science, they would likely
be vaccinated at a much higher rate if Trump
were president today.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
But I don't think I think I would be lying
to you if I denied that.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
September 18th.
Saturday might be Trump riots.
Number two, we will talk about the measures,
security measures that police are taking in
DC.
In advance of that, corporations try to blame
individuals for the plastic crisis.
Oh, you got to recycle that bottle.
Now, states are starting to turn the tables
on corporations, and Salesforce is offering
to relocate Texas based employees on the basis
of the Texas abortion law.
Very interesting what Salesforce is doing.
We will talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show.
Sign up at Join Pakman.